damn oh shoot that did work
okay well all right then friends um
welcome to my January live stream
Q&A um
yeah so this is an evening when yall can
ask me uh any questions that come to
mind about pois spinning flow arts or
really anything else you can uh think of
too um yeah so I've tried out something
new this time around in that um so there
there's the whole Super Chat function
for the channel which um is that lovely
little button that has a dollar sign in
the middle of it and uh if you hit that
you can drop a tip to the
channel and um that uh that comes
straight to me uh YouTube does not keep
any portion of it and so apparently
YouTube has now activated a feature
where you can create a goal with
that so um I set a goal of 10 super
chats we'll see how that goes
tonight uh I will say that that uh I
don't think I've ever had that number of
Super chats but we'll see if it happens
tonight first though I need some viewers
out there
um oh I do have some viewers now that's
excellent there's there so there there's
a delay on what I get to see on my end
so if there's people that are out there
watching please chime off in the chat
let me know that you're
there so as I can say hello and let me
know where you're uh where you're coming
from too where watching
from I'm always curious about these
things also I feel like there's way too
much light behind me here so I'm going
to turn
off that
one things still seem like really hazy
in my room though I don't uh in my
living room I don't know why that
is we got Josh Reyes waving Hello Cheers
from I think that's California
650 and we've got John Alo hi I'm
watching from South Carolina Carrie hi
Drex hi from DC hello Carrie uh Carrie
is one of my students in my uh live
stream classes so hello Carrie it's
great to have you here
tonight and as it turns out we live in
the same metro area although I don't
think we've ever met each other face to
face which is funny but um as you can
hear of course uh my voice is a wee bit
froggy tonight I'm getting over a cold
this is still far better than my voice
sounded at the beginning of this week so
uh congratulations oh I hang
on I know why it's hazy it's because the
lens is
dirty
um this is going to be really really
janky but give me just one second and I
will wipe off all these lenses and
hopefully that will
help oh I
camera One camera
two did that help at
all yeah you know I think that did help
cool good job Drex uh Carrie highly
recommend drex's live classes have
learned a ton well thank you Carrie I
really appreciate
that um yeah so I do these um monthly
q&as and uh they exist for you all to be
able to jump in and uh be able to uh ask
me questions about whatever you have in
mind Josh Rya oh Anthony says woot uh
Joshua rehea says I see Katan in the
background love that game I've got a a
lovely game collection back here I I
would say so the the new one on the far
left is apiary and I just got that for
Christmas this year from my brother
right next to it you can barely see it
is another game made by the same company
called wingspan wingspan is very fun but
it drives me crazy because it takes
longer to explain the game than it does
to play it uh next to that of course is
Katan and then aul and hiding behind aul
is uh code names and next up is happy
little dinosaurs and then Saku and then
set Hanabi and a deck of playing cards
so uh yes I love me some games oh and
and ER and there's a new uh collectible
card game uh based around dinosaurs that
my girlfriend got me for Christmas that
is down on the Shelf below I I think I'm
at a position where I need to uh start
passing off some of my games to friends
cuz the the gaming shelf is is getting
to be a little packed up
there but yeah no I love TableTop games
uh my I have uh friends here in DC we
get together once a month for uh a
gaming night so um I tend to learn new
uh tabletop and uh card games during
that and uh I bring in my favorites as
well um so yeah I I love me uh I love me
some uh some
games yeah
so yeah this is a Q&A y'all have
questions for me out there please drop
them in the chat and also just as a
reminder for those of you who popped on
a little bit late um Super Chat helps
out the channel That is is that little
square button with the dollar sign in it
it's basically like tipping me uh the
money comes straight to me uh YouTube
does not keep even a dime of that uh
it's all for me so um yeah that's a
great way to show your appreciation for
me and for the channel uh and also too
uh for the first time I tried setting a
goal which is to get 10 super chats
tonight we'll see if that actually
happens
um yeah so um and also too if you leave
a Super Chat uh so I tend to answer
answer questions in the order that they
come in more or less so if you want your
chat uh kind of you can jump the que
with your question if you leave me a
Super Chat oh hooray Carrie thank you so
much Carrie left the Super Chat yay I
appreciate you so much so very much um
oh and you do have a question in in the
uh queue too that's excellent oh I I can
like it so I shall I shall outstanding
um yeah uh if you want to ask another
question to Carrie you can but I will
answer your first question uh first so
um very much enjoy your YouTube
performance videos why thank you so much
um what are you excited to be working on
in the new year um right now and this is
a really really really aggressive goal
right now um I have well so I I have a
couple projects that I've got lined up
right now one of which is
um so um I am a reconnecting Sami that
is um my ancestors uh were uh indigenous
to the area of Northern Europe above the
Arctic Circle and I've been reconnecting
with that part of my past inheritage of
late and um there is a Sami holiday
called uh Sami national day that uh
happens on February
6th February 6th is it yes February 6th
uh every year to celebrate the uh
creation of the first Sami Congress
which was um uh is like a tribal
Congress that brought together Sami
people from Norway Sweden and uh Finland
to uh talk about uh tribal matters and
Lobby the governments of all of those
different countries for uh greater
indigenous
rights um so there's a really marvelous
song that uh apparently won top prize at
the uh at the SII Grand Prix a couple
years ago it is a uh a song called um
D um I'm trying to remember the name of
the artist on it it
is where are we here
um the song is called dooel uh
d s t i
l
and it is
by if I can play my playlist here oh I
can just look it up just by the song
name I think Duo
steel yeah uh it's a song by an artist
by the name of uh iy
and I am choreographing something to
that song I only have a couple of weeks
to do this in and shoot a performance
around it so it's a pretty it's a really
really really aggressive goal but um I I
I believe in me I believe I believe I
can pull this one off so be on the
lookout for that um it's also just a
great pop song in general and it
showcases um so there is a uh
traditional Sami vocal art called
um uh Y and um there's a part of the
song that is performed in Y which is um
kind of a a
chanting um the the yo part of the song
is
hey um it sounds very very very similar
to uh the style of singing that you know
we we associate with uh uh Native
Americans as well um and I'm I actually
started uh taking lessons on how to Y so
uh I'm I'm really excited about that and
I'm excited to perform to this song so
um yeah the other thing is that um for
many months now I have been working on a
video essay about my thoughts on PO
dance and specifically how we compose
movement and performances and I have
written and Rewritten and edited and
re-edited that essay more times than I
can count and I am so hoping that I will
have it out sometime in the first
quarter here so th those are the two
projects I have ahead of me that I'm
excited for great
question um John Alo says where can I
check out the live classes I'm so glad
you
asked
so the uh
current class can be
accessed here
oop will it not let me paste it
strange there we go okay cool uh so John
that's where you can access the class um
and uh that's the current class we got
two weeks left in it uh usually the way
it works is that I'll I'll teach for
four weeks and then we'll take a week
off and then come back for another
four-week session um all of the CL each
and every session of the classes is
recorded Ed um so if you want to join
the class halfway through that's totally
fine you can go back and watch the first
two classes um this session has been
specifically about playing around with
levels and volume in uh POI performance
and dance um I'm not going to lie this
is probably my favorite session that
I've taught so far I made a lot of
changes to how to my how I was teaching
the class and I think a lot of them are
for the better um so I I've really been
enjoying it and uh of course every class
tops off with I will teach you a bit of
Po choreography and we all learn and
perform together which I think is is
pretty
incredible so do go please check that
out John um we'd love to have you we'd
love to have you um yeah so uh Carrie
thank you once again for the Super Chat
I appreciate you if anybody else wants
to help me reach my goal Super Chat it
helps the channel just like it says in
the bottom of the screen there
um
sweet so um those are the only two
questions I see in the queue anybody
else have any questions out there looks
like we've we've only the um this so
there's a delay on the stats as I'm
watching them and it says that there's
only five people watching right now I
don't uh so I don't know what is the
actual current number but that was the
number a few minutes ago
so Carrie says she's happy to ask more
questions please do keep them coming
keep them coming
ah whatever you got on your
mind Carrie and anybody else if anybody
else has questions please uh ple please
send them through I can teach you tricks
I can explain Concepts I can also like I
did with Carrie just explain things
about how I approach things and anything
else you have on your
mind so bring it on
should I start I I I should start like
humming the theme to Jeopardy
here oh also I should note that if I um
if I make my goal here and get 10 oh
it's fine Carrie Carrie says sorry it's
taking me a while to type no take your
time take your time um
in order to set up the uh Super Chat
goal for the evening I had to uh
basically uh kind of set a thing that's
like what will you do if you reach your
Super Chat goal so the Super Chat goal
is if I get 10 super chats tonight um I
will flow out to the song of y'all's
choosing uh whatever y'all vote for out
in um the chat land there because uh I
am I'm rather notorious for uh avoiding
um uh spinning to EDM songs so if you
want to watch me spin to an EDM song
fill up those super chats and and
request it in in the chat there that
that's the way to make that happen um
Anthony uh also I've been watching you
since you were since you were going to
school since I was going to school I
started spinning
how long was it I think I started
spending three or four years after I
graduated from college so I'm not I'm
not sure what uh what
school um if you you thought I was
attending there uh I always wondered if
you got a degree from that school and
what it was did you ever do anything
with that degree like get a job or do
anything with it do anything worthwhile
love you by the way keep it up yeah
um my degree is from the University of
Colorado at Boulder um the same town
that I grew up in um and my degree is in
so by Quirk of how they count the
credits um my degree is in American
history um did I do anything and I I
should also note that in my undergrad
um uh I I I I studied um history in many
different parts of the world and also
like I did some really specific history
classes too like um there was a class on
the history of the mining industry in
the United States so I know way more
than I should about how we mine for
minerals um and how mining impacted the
development of the American West um I
also took a really amazing class on um
the history of space exploration so
there's yeah I I can also tell you a lot
about uh man the most fascinating char I
read about in that class was a guy named
uh corev who was a Russian writer who in
the early part of the 20th century
basically came up with the idea for like
multi-stage rockets and um space
stations and things like that and it
took most of the century for technology
to catch up to his ideas and very
explicitly both the Soviet and American
space programs were like built in His
image like he he's the guy who came up
with all of the ideas for what
eventually became the core principles of
um of of space travel uh and you know he
wasn't a physicist he wasn't I don't
think he was even a scientist but um
really really fascinating guy like
everybody who was involved in the Space
Race had read his stuff and was uh and
was inspired by him really cool dude um
I also took uh I if ID had the option I
would have majored in Middle Eastern
history as it was I maxed out the number
of classes that the University of
Colorado offered on uh Middle Eastern
history um I
also uh Japanese history was another one
that I took a a fair number of classes
in um so yeah that's what my degree is
in I'm I'm I I am actually a historian
uh I I have the training for it which
really it's just training on how to do
research um
yeah well no that's not entirely true
it's training on how to do research and
interpret the results cuz like you it's
one thing to find the data and it's
another to draw conclusions from it and
half the job of a historian is to draw
conclusions from it for sure um so yeah
that that's what my degree is in and um
did I ever use it I mean yeah I I I
actually think I use it constantly um
whenever I write a video essay for my
channel on the history of flow Arts it's
because I'm applying all of those uh
skills that I learned in my undergrad
for creating uh for for for creating
video essays on Flow arts history so
yeah yeah I I I use it constantly um I I
will be the first to admit that um I do
not think I
I I have read a great number of
historians and I continue to be
um I I I continue to be a fan of of many
historians out there um stepen Ambrose
of course was was an incredible
historian uh Doris Kerns Goodwin uh love
her work
um and uh there's uh a podcast that I
really love the podcast host Mike Duncan
um I don't believe he's got a degree in
history but he might as well cuz he he
definitely like um the way that he
approaches doing research on given topic
um you know he he's got uh he's got the
real world um history degree there for
sure the School of Hard Knocks um big
fan of his work
um the book he wrote that I read last
year was um uh Hero Of Two Worlds it was
a biography of the Marquee de Lafayette
um the French uh Major General who
fought with the American in the uh in
the Revolutionary War fascinating figure
because basically um he runs away from
home to go enj to go join the
Revolutionary War it's incredibly
scandalous um he comes from one of the
wealth maybe the no one of the
wealthiest families at the time in
France and so um it's a huge Scandal
that he runs away from home to do this
and so he feels an enormous amount of
pressure to prove himself um as a
military AR Commander because um being a
young nobleman
he basically the way France was set up
at the time was that um he was going to
get channeled into court life at uh at
at
Versailles which he didn't particularly
like he wanted to be on the battlefield
and um he didn't want to be a cordier he
didn't want to um he didn't want to uh
play the political game he he wanted to
go out and fight and find glory on the
battlefield and he did in the American
Revolutionary War and then it's very
strange because he goes back to France
and the French Revolution starts up and
at first he is a figure that people look
to um with some reverence because you
know the the French Revolution they
totally thought themselves um kind of
philosophical neighbors of um of the
Americans and uh Lafayette did too but
very very quickly as France Got
progressively more and more radical
during the uh French Revolution he very
quickly found himself um flanked to the
left by you know Ro Spear and St ju and
all of the um Whatchamacallit uh the uh
the
Jacobin um and eventually um found
himself in
a long and short is is that he
basically he didn't technically um
because he was captured in battle but he
he basically fled France um for the for
the duration of the French Revolution
and came to be seen as a conservative
and regressive figure by many of the key
figures in the French Revolution
because uh you know number one he was he
was part of the nobility he uh he was um
you know
he from a noble family one of the
wealthiest uh men in France and um when
push came to shove the government that
he imagined for France was a
constitutional monarchy he didn't want
to get rid of he didn't want to get rid
of the king um and again he was just
rapidly outflanked on the left by the
more radical elements in the French
Revolution and eventually it cost him
respect uh in the with the French public
and to this day uh he doesn't have a
terribly good
reputation in terms of how he navigated
the French Revolution the French don't
think much of him but we Americans do
it's really fascinating wow I'm going
off on such an info dump here sorry I'm
going to pull it back together um yes I
use my degree constantly and as you can
tell um I I I keep up to date on topics
that uh interest me um my mygre Great
American history my focus area was on
the uh Colonial to revolutionary era up
to about uh the election of Andrew
Jackson so until about like mid 19th
century um I'm not as strong on
basically like Civil War up to World War
II but the postwar period uh I feel I I
I feel pretty solid in my knowledge on
so if youall have any history questions
you can always hit me up too thanks for
uh thanks for sticking with me there as
I went down that uh that that uh that
tangent so yes I I use my degree
frequently
um oh my goodness yes I missed a bunch
of things in the class or in the chat
here Carrie asks uh I changed the grip
from forefinger and thumb to tether
between my fingers due to some
tendinitis I feel like this gives me
less control over the POI any advice for
keeping the PO in place yeah so that's
tough um when you switch grips like that
it's it's really um it it is quite
disorienting at first without a doubt I
don't know if this is an option for you
but there is something I can suggest so
um so to to get everybody else up to
speed and switch the camera for the
first time tonight um so like uh for the
most part when I teach people po I'm
teaching them using what we call the key
grip that is this grip where you're kind
of pinching the tether between uh your
thumb and the second nle nug knuckle of
your uh index finger and I feel like
this gives you a lot of fine-tuned
control over the movement of the POI uh
and of course whenever you wrap the POI
around your hands to shorten them you
kind of wind up in the key grip by
default anyway um it also does need to
be said that it takes some hand strength
to do this um and I can definitely see
how it would cause some
tendinitis um I actually do have one of
my private lesson students right now is
um a slightly older woman who uh
likewise has problems maintaining uh
tensil grip uh with her fingers and she
also uh prefers is to use this grip
where the PO are controlled uh between
two fingers like so instead of being
pinched now um the because everybody
produces poy with handles these days the
kind of default way to do this is just
to kind of have the tether poking out
between your index finger and your
middle finger and anchoring the PO
handle then between those two fingers um
as Terry is saying it does sometimes
lead to less fine control uh you can I
mean drilling with it practicing a lot
will help you get some of that back
you're also going to wind up with
calluses uh between your two fingers
here as a result of it um and that's
just kind of a given with po anyway you
you have to build up your calluses at
first so what are your options here to
be frank with you um probably your best
option is to change out the type of
handle um so many
companies still offer an option for
finger Loops now you can anchor the your
fingers uh in the finger Loops like so
you just poke them through and you wind
up with and I will say that I prefer uh
a finger Loop grip where it attaches to
the second knuckle just like if I were
to use the key grip
the reason being that I can find uh a
better degree of control then by
articulating my fingers as I spin your
mileage may
vary um but I find this helpful I find
it a good compromise in terms of
maintaining control while still also
doing so in a place where um you're not
uh you're you're not uh having problems
with grip there is a third option there
is a third
option and that is um and you can do
this with either type of handle but I'll
demonstrate it right quick with this one
so um notice how my my first uh approach
to doing this grip was to stick my index
and middle fingers through the finger
Loops here and then have the end poking
out um kind of uh pointing away from my
Knuckles here's another option
you can have the uh the the tether and
everything kind of pointed down towards
the floor and your palm pointed towards
the floor and stick your pinky and ring
fingers through it and go back to the
key grip wait I thought we were trying
to avoid the key grip well here's the
thing because the tether is now anchored
between these two fingers you don't
require as much tensile strength to hold
on to the tether anymore so you can have
the kind of control that you're used to
having with the key grip but it doesn't
take as much effort from your hand to
maintain it you can also do the same
thing with a ball
handle where you can anchor it between
your pinky and your ring finger like so
and then use the traditional key grip
and once again you should have uh it
won't be as snug it won't be as secure
as if you're using finger Loops but
it'll also get the job done you'll be
able to use the control point of the key
grip uh while not needing to keep a
death grip on the tether and hopefully
save the tendons in your hands and
fingers which um I feel for you and uh I
know it's only a matter of time before
that's coming for me too um which fun
fact uh during quarantine when I was
uploading videos every single day
um whenever I shoot a video and I get a
take that I want to hold on to I snap my
fingers twice so that when I'm going
back and
editing I can see the uh the spike in
the audio waveform where that happened
and I know to cut the video right there
rather than having to watch the entire
video to find out where I got the take
right and where I didn't I snap my
fingers once if I blew the take and
twice if I got the take now the thing is
that's totally fine if I'm only shooting
video once or twice a week but when I'm
doing it each and every day I got the
worst tendonitis from snapping my finger
so often it was uh it was not a good
time um but tendonitis spinning Poise
probably coming my way too oh goodness
we have another Super Chat
yay from Dan Campbell thank you so much
Dan uh if you have any question
questions for me um pretty please drop
them in the chat and I oh oh you did
have a question attached to it you were
doing this
right um what the heck is going on I'm
giving a live stream Q&A uh no I don't
care just trolling and saying hello
awesome well thank you thank you so much
Dan I appreciate you thank you for the
super chats and if you think of any
other questions please let me know um I
I will be more than happy to jump you up
in the queue there all right let's see
what else we got
here
um a couple people it appears did enjoy
my my info dumps about history uh about
corev and uh marqu de Lafayette so
that's good to see that's a good skill
to have yeah so you use it all the time
says dizzy yes I do uh Dizzy's my
girlfriend everybody Dizzy's Dizzy's the
one who got me the uh collectible card
game uh about dinosaurs that I was
pointing out earlier hey honey um
Joshua Reyes asks what do you think
about the Tik Tock
ban how long do you have my man how long
do you
have
um so I'm I'm going to start this off by
saying that I have been avoiding getting
into into the discourse that I've been
seeing about this online now for several
days
I've been seeing people
um i' I've been seeing a lot of
discourse going back and forth and I've
definitely been like you know people are
people are having a tough time over this
and I don't know that my thoughts are
going to help out a lot of people who
are who are having a tough time with
it I will do my best to give brief
thoughts here and I know that I will not
succeed but we'll I'll I'll try anyway
um
so I have never been much of a fan of
Tik Tok I don't like the interface I
don't think that it is a super Creator
friendly platform in
general um partially because
like
so Tik Tok is designed to be an
incredibly user and viewer friendly
platform and that means that a lot of
control is taken away from creators and
it is put in the hands of the end users
that makes a lot of things difficult for
creators um not the least of which Hank
Green put this really beautifully uh
Hank Green of uh Vlog Brothers when he
said that um YouTube is is a platform
where you have to choose what you're
going to watch and you have to click on
it that means that you already have a
base level of Engagement with anything
that uh you watch on YouTube and it
generally means that creators on YouTube
wind up having a very close relationship
with their audiences because their
audiences um are making a very conscious
choice to come into their world with Tik
Tok it's not a question of clicking on
the video it's a question of clicking
off the video
you're basically just being given a fire
hose of uh
content
and your job then is to decide when
you're bored and you want to move on
um and so that creates an environment
that I think is not really great for
education or for creating the same kinds
of um relationships with one's audience
that I'm used to on YouTube and even
Instagram for that matter um so I've
never been particularly fond of uh Tik
Tok as a platform um that said I
recognize that it's a platform that
means a lot to quite a lot of people um
I have friends who have done very very
well on the platform
and what I think Tik Tok has done a
really incredible job of is creating a
really specific kind of
community it's a community
that um
feels
strangely
um strangely exclusive in some ways in
that like
people people really feel a kinship with
other uh Tik Tok creators and
collaborate with them in ways that
like um that they don't on other
platforms and I definitely see that um
all that said
um I I am definitely one of those that
has questions about Tik Tock and by
extension fite dances uh
relationship with the Chinese
government
um I think data
is one of the most important
assets to have for any any entity in in
the 21st
century and we've got no shortage of
social media companies here in the
United States but like if the government
wants data from them it has to you know
file a warrant and the company can
contest it and they can take it to court
and this has happened and
so there are guard rails uh on that
process I'm not saying the guard rails
have always worked as they're designed
to but there are guard rails there are
no guard rails in China um if the
Chinese government wants any data
whatsoever from bite dance they have to
cough it up um we don't know if this has
happened it you know
there's it is something that is
theoretically possible but that um so
far as I know there has never we don't
have any official record of an incident
where it happened that doesn't mean that
it hasn't and that may come out in the
future but as of right now we don't have
record of it um I understand the
motivation behind the Tik Tok band and I
I don't think it's incorrect
um I also have empathy for people who
are on the platform and feel like
they're losing a
community one of those things that I
learned as a content creator many many
many many years ago was that it was a
good idea to
diversify uh the platforms that I was on
this is why I mean I still consider
myself a YouTube Native but I'm also on
Instagram um I'm also on threads I'm on
Twitter um and you know of course I have
always posted just enough content on Tik
Tok to keep the lights on so to speak
um and
so in my mind as soon as you're
really serious about creating content
the next step is to make sure that
you're you're engaged in that that
you're on the platforms that you need to
be like it it's the same thing as
diversifying income sources I don't have
just one income stream I have multiple
income streams and that's because if an
a Calamity comes along that knocks out
one of those income streams it means
that I'm not going to
starve um and the same thing is true for
being a content creator on social
media you have to make sure you're on
multiple platforms this is why even
though I don't like Tik Tok as a
platform I'm still on it I recognize
that it has its use and that there are
people on it and people can discover me
through
it Tik Tok is so very interesting to me
because the cohesion with which it has
created that Community is such that a
lot of people who are on it just do not
seem to see another option for
themselves as content creators of other
places they can go that Tik talk is the
only place where they can engage with an
audience and other creators in the way
that they want to I'm not here to tell
them that that's not true but at the
same time
um and and there are pieces of this that
like I I'm not quite sure of whether you
know this is just part of Tik Tock
culture that that you know
people kind of uh stay there so to speak
um that they don't really experiment
with with other content platforms as
much or whether you know the platform
itself is kind of like you know oh you
you won't find this kind of relationship
anywhere else and you know people have
have just kind of gone for it I don't
know the answer to that um what I do
know is that um Tik Tock being banned
is not going to have a huge impact on
the work that I
create
um it's going to have an impact on other
creators that I know and again I I feel
empathy for them and you know
I I I absolutely think that they should
take time to mourn the community that
they're going to be losing there
um but at the same time I hope that
there some percentage of them that
decide that Now's the Time to diversify
their platforms and seek out audiences
on other platforms as well um at least
if they want to keep on uh creating
content so we shall see um I don't feel
like I need to to mourn Tik Tok
personally but um again I'm a YouTube
Native and it must be said if uh if
YouTube were suddenly banned for
whatever reason I would certainly mourn
the platform um I I would be able to
keep on doing what I'm doing but um it
would I would C I certainly have an
emotional attachment to the platform so
uh I do have empathy for those who have
an emotional uh connection to Tik Tok
for
sure
um so yeah I think that's I think that's
about the most diplomatic way I can put
my thoughts together right now that's
uh I take that for what it's worth
I'm also not entirely convinced that the
uh that the ban is going to last um it
sounds like Trump is signaling that he
may reverse the ban when he comes into
office uh which would be really funny if
like Tik Tok takes down the app over the
weekend and then on Tuesday it's back up
um we'll see we'll see but yeah that was
a bunch of thoughts on the topic I hope
something in there was useful but uh
yeah good question actually I enjoy
getting questions like that cuz they uh
they they
they they make me use my
Noggin
um
Martin Balin says please make a diamond
flowers tutorial I've made several
Diamond Flowers tutorials my friend
several of them let me see if I can pull
one up for you
here um
what was the last one I
did I
did yeah I mean I did a series of them
during the pandemic so I'll link you to
the uh first one in that series and
maybe it'll suggest the others then
too can I reply directly to you that's
the
question nope
lame
okay cool
all right
so uh Jillian danin asks what is the
best way to choreograph a full song I
don't know if you figure it out let me
know no I'm just kidding uh do it in 30
seconds using the Instagram audio or a
different way so
um I think that that method has its
pluses and its negatives um it's the the
positives are that it breaks the song up
into bite-sized pieces uh it makes it
more manageable the downside is is that
when you put the pieces back together
very frequently you find out that you
have pacing issues in the full
song um and sometimes you find that
there are sections that are a little bit
too repetitive because they were
choreographed in isolation from each
other and when you put them back
together all of a sudden it's like ah
shoot I didn't know I repeated myself
here so
um I think that it's a fine tool but be
aware that you might have to rec
choreograph some sections uh when you
put them all together but that's that's
not the end of the world um I don't
think there is one best way to
choreograph a full song um I've done
several different approaches to putting
to to choreographing a full song and I
don't know that I believe that anyone is
superior to the others I think it's
whatever gets you from uh from point A
to point B sometimes you have a story
you want to tell sometimes um you just
kind of have a movement theme you want
to work through and sometimes you just
break it up into 30 second slots and see
if you can choreograph a full song
around that I guess like um the biggest
thing would I would put out there is
just in terms of choreographing a full
song ask yourself why am I
choreographing to this song specifically
what is it about this song that makes me
want to write uh 2 or 3 minutes worth of
choreography um that is going to be
what's going to sustain you through the
process um and it's going to be what
grounds you through the process too so
um good luck with that that's that it
feels like that's the that is an
uncharacteristically short answer for me
on a topic like that I I yeah
um a short answer is there's no one
right way there's no one best way um but
doing it in 30 second
increments absolutely will work and if
you're just starting off it's not a bad
way to go about it it's it it'll it'll
get the job done it'll get the job done
um Carrie says hi Jillian so both Julian
and Carrie are in my live stream classes
hello to you both uh Julian says hi
Carrie it's lovely seeing you um Carrie
says super thank you very helpful I'm
guessing you're saying that about the
grip thing dizzy says hey handsome a
hello beautiful um
Martin Balin says also stalls at left
and right same directions
async I have no idea what that
means
um can
you is there a video you can link me to
that shows this in action cuz I from
that description I don't have a clue
what you're describing uh sorry uh
Delaney mclin says I recently got the
LED POI with the loop handles um my
first POI I'm wondering if the shape or
weight of the POI affects the look or
feel of actually performing yes it does
uh like sphere shape versus the teardrop
yes in fact I can show you
examples okay so I have several
different types of
LEDs and I'm going to give you a
demonstration of some of the things that
they're capable
of um so because they're made by the
same company and they have a lot of the
same modes I'm going to start you off by
taking a look
at what mode do you want want to do
here cool so I'm going to start you off
with floa poy here which are contact POI
now things I want you to notice about
the contact POI the thing we always
focus on with contact poy of course is
doing contact tricks rolling the ball
around on parts of your body
but contact poy when they were first
marketed were not called Contact POI
they were called pendulum POI because
the first thing that people noticed
about Rona McLaughlin's style back in
the day was was his use of pendulums and
how cool contact poy made pendulums look
they also make stalls look really cool
like say if you're going to do udas
stalls like so um because they focus all
of the attention on one point in space
you can do things like say um you know
playing around with
um point isolations or stop
we're having that one point of interest
in space really helps guide the eye uh
in specific ways um I personally think
that contact POI are not as effective
for things like flowers and the like
because um you wind up losing a lot of
the performance volume uh in most cases
we're we're meant to not pay attention
to the tethers of the contact poy
because they draw our attention to the
tips so much um so that's why I think
stalls and uh Point isolations work
really well with uh contact poy uh
another thing they're really good for is
plane breaks the reason being that um
when you perform plane braks there's
always just a little bit of
uh it's not always precise you know
sometimes you get that plane perfectly
and some sometimes you don't and contact
po will hide it if you don't get the
plane perfect because again the focus is
on the POI heads and so if you're a
little bit off in your plane it's not
going to be as visible with contact
poy now let's take a look at Popp and
flow
poy so these have a rod shaped form
factor they look very similar to
programmable poy and the first thing
you're going to notice is that the very
thing that um
the contact poy are good for these are
terrible at whenever I perform a point
isolation like so I can see them jiggle
around the reason being that um the
weight distribution along the length of
it isn't the same as it is with the
contact poy where I have all this Mass
down here and then tether I have all
this lighting area right here which is
solid in plastic and then I have a more
flexible tether on the end of it so I
personally think that stalls and even
plane braks don't tend to look very good
with rod-shaped uh form factors because
they give away the game they show more
of the length of the poy and so if
you're planes are off it reads clear's
day to the audience what are they good
for hey it's those flowers that I said
that contact po were less good fit for
why because since so much more of the
surface is lit up we can actually see
the full area of the flower as we're
spinning it here um they also make
spiral wraps look pretty
cool um I recommend using pendulums most
of the time for any transitions that
you're going to do with form factors
like this um let me see here oh they're
also great for like uh body
tracers I think so final
option there is there are actually like
two
companies that make uh LED
Socko and led sock are very interesting
to me because um in some respects they
behave like contact POI and in some
respects they behave like the rod shaped
POI they behave like the rod shaped POI
in that um they're great for flowers
they illuminate the full area around the
performer so that uh you're taking up
that full volume with the POI uh and
crucially stalls don't look bad with
them uh you can do your point isolations
and now because the weight is Con
concentrated down in the head again and
there's a pretty
consistent uh weight and flexibility
going from the head to the handle uh it
means that we're no longer wibbly wobbly
when we do our stalls out to the side
here or our point isolations which is
great um and of course they'll do all
the fun things that they they won't you
can't do contact PO with them
unfortunately um but they have a lot of
the same strengths as contact po as well
as a lot of the same strengths
as the uh Rod shaped uh programmable PO
for
sure um I will say uh they do have some
of the uh flaws of each one too so like
for instance um just like with the rod
form factor if you do plane braks with
them and you're off by even a little
it's going to be clear as day to your
audience I actually really like
practicing plane brakes with sock p
because since they give away the game on
that um they tend to make me more
precise when I do do my plane brakes and
that then translates to even cleaner
planes when I switch back to contact poy
um in terms of um the weaknesses that
they have in common with contact poy as
you can clearly see here the
illumination doesn't always go all the
way to the end of the tether so
sometimes they don't fill up as much
space around you as they possibly could
um the rod shaped version definitely
gives you more illumination and more
coverage than these do um but these are
kind of a good middle ground between the
two for sure um so yeah those are my
thoughts
I have actually thought about doing a
video explaining all of these thoughts
let me know in the comments if you'd
like to see me make that video
shut these off so I'm not just burning
through the
battery awesome great
question
um see here we're getting near the uh
we're getting near the end of the hour
here any chance anybody else wants to
leave me a super chat here I put down a
goal of 10 which I know was ambitious
but uh hoping we can uh hoping we can
maybe get to five five maybe maybe we'll
see
um yeah so uh Delany I hope that was
helpful I hope that was
helpful um Jillian dankin asks how do
you listen to the parts of the song on
repeat to perfect the moves so you can
choreograph the full song Perfectly
yeah so this actually drives me crazy
too um cuz you'll be working on a
specific part of the song you'll have to
like go back and move the uh and like
track it to the place that you wanted in
the song um I will say that like uh you
can use Instagram for that so like pull
the song up and select the part of the
song that you want to choreograph to and
just leave it going because it'll just
automatically Loop
then um one thing I will say is I think
it's a good idea to have two devices is
going at any given time one that has the
music going and the other one that
records video of you as you're kind of
workshopping your way through stuff I
cannot count the number of times where
I've been working on choreographing
something and I like either discard or
completely forget about an idea very
early on in the
process and
um I'll just be going back through and
watching the early takes of it and just
like oh shoot why why did I why did I
leave that one uh by the wayside why
didn't I uh why didn't I I
I why didn't I take that idea further so
make sure your documenting is off oh
hey Delaney mclocklin left me another
Super Chat thank you Delaney you're a
rock star let me know if you have any
other questions I will be happy to uh to
answer them appreciate you appreciate
you very much um so yeah I'd say like
because Instagram will automatically
Loop stuff for you pull up the song on
Instagram take it to the section that
you want to work on and um have another
camera going to record your work so that
you have um you have some reference
there that that is what I would
say
um Martin says the Stalls I mean are the
ones you used even in the video for
reversing
direction of spin when same
direction what
the Stalls are the ones you
used even in that
video which video for reversing
direction of spin when same
direction are you talking about the
diamond anti-spin
tutorial um can you give me a time stamp
for what you're talking about in that
video that'd be
helpful um Jillian says thank you this
is very helpful you're so welcome
Jillian says how do
you Palm up and palm down
catch
um uh Palm up and palm down
catch do you mean just like catching the
poy head um here
[Applause]
so what I think that oh hang on hang on
hang on all right um
Martin are you talking about this bunch
of business right here if so chime off
in the chat and let me know um or are
you talking about this bunch of business
right here I don't know
umm bum bum
yeah chime off in the chat let me know
which one of those things it is um so
Jillian what I think you're talking
about is something like say that or like
that which I've been referring to as G
snatches because um there's a PO Spinner
by the name in G who would do a thing
that we called uh a GP where he would uh
switch the position in relation to the
Hand by cracking the poy almost like a
whip so he something he would often do
is like he would do stalls up and down
boom and switch
it like so um and so in my mind doing
one of these is basically doing a GP but
then catching it um so the way that I do
this is that I uh open up my hand and
use these three fingers to do the catch
um so when I like stall up I like pull
it down
and I'm pinching the T hether between my
index finger and um the uh and and uh
the edge of my hand and that frees up my
thumb and the other three
fingers
boom to catch the head like so and that
winds up being the same whether my palm
is pointed up or my palm is pointed down
it's the exact same process I'm freeing
up my my three smallest fingers and my
thumb in order to make the catch happen
in the meantime I'm uh anchoring the
tether by uh kind of hooking my index
finger around it and holding it tight
against the top part of my hand that is
that is how we do
that
um Delan mland says thank you for your
answer very helpful I'm so glad to hear
that I'm so glad to hear that was
helpful yay um Jillian says thank you
this answer is so helpful really
appreciate the answers I even write the
tricks down it comes up with so I
remember what they are excellent yes
that's also that's also a good approach
that is also a good approach for
sure um so we are at five minutes past
the hour right now and it it at least
from the uh analytics I'm looking at it
does appear as though um people are
either uh hopping off or uh I am I'm I'm
schedu scheduled across from something
so um Martin if you want to jump in
right quick with clarification on that
stalls question I'll see what I can do
to help you out
um and if not um it might be time to
wind it down we'll see we'll see do
you'all want me to stay on for like 10
minutes more just just for grins if
anybody else has uh questions they'd
like answered I can I can make that
happen um Julian says thank you this is
very helpful I really appreciate you
explaining this
absolutely my
pleasure uh Julian asks can we go over
antipin Flowers in our private lessons
yes we can absolutely yeah yeah no I
think uh I think you're ready to start
exploring anti- spin flowers for sure uh
I Jillian is one of my private lessons
students um I offer private lessons I I
am I currently have one slot open that
I'm trying to fill so if you're
interested in it you can email me at
Drex drexfactor
have some interested parties but uh as
always the devil's in the details and
trying to get things uh
scheduled
so uh yeah if y'all are interested in
that that's how uh you could maybe snag
up that slot
yourself um yeah so how we doing out
there we want to
uh oh that's weird
oh I see why I see
why gotcha there was something in the
chat I was uh I was I was a little
curious about but yeah um yeah I'll tell
you what everybody I will go to 8:15 my
time so if uh if there's additional
questions out there uh please let me
know
and even though the the counter says
that we've only got two we've actually
got three of the super chats so if there
are two more people out there who want
to who want to drop a Super Chat let's
see if we can get it to five let's see
if we can get it to
five um Jillian says I think anti-spin
flowers are too in-depth for the live
stream no actually I don't think they
are at all I can I can give you the
basic techniques for anti-spin flowers
over live stream pretty easily it's the
application of them it is using both of
your hands at the same time to create
anti-spin flowers that is going to be
challenging
there um that might be a bridge too far
um for live stream but I can at least
give you the basics of anti-spin flowers
for sure uh which if anybody wants that
let me know in the chat we definitely
have enough time to to work that
in and any other questions you might
have drop them in the chat let me know
what's going on
ber I am also good to wind things down
too if uh if if people out there are
getting tired which given that it keeps
telling me that I'm dropping down to
like five viewers from 10 uh it seems
like that might be the case um dizzy
asks do you have any projects and the
works that you're willing to talk about
yeah actually so um Carrie asked the
same question uh
earlier in the chat and I'm I'm happy to
repeat it um the answer which is that um
two projects on the horizon that uh I'm
I I'm I'm excited about that uh I I want
to complete um the first one is
um for those who were not here at the
beginning um I am uh I'm a reconnecting
Sami that is um my ancestors were
indigenous people from Finland and um
I've kind of been in the process of uh
reconnecting with that culture because
my family assimilated uh a few
Generations ago and
um I came across a song by a Sami singer
named uh II uh called called D and um
every year on February 6th uh we
celebrate uh Sami national day which uh
celebrates the first time that a Sami
Congress uh met together um to work on
uh tribal issues and Lobby the
governments of Norway Sweden and Finland
uh for recognition of indigenous rights
um and so for uh Sami National Day this
year I want to choreograph a piece to uh
D and um that's only a few weeks away so
it's a really aggressive goal but I'm
going to try nonetheless we'll see we'll
we'll we'll see if I get there and how
good the choreography is when I get
there but um the other project is one
that I've had sitting around on the back
burner now for many many many months and
that
is um basically like a an essay or uh a
Manifesto essentially outlin
my thoughts on what makes for good po
performances in choreography what it is
I look for um what it is I think makes
po choreography
beautiful I I I have written and
Rewritten this script so many times but
um I want to get it out this year I
really want to get it out this year so
fingers crossed that I get there th
those are the two projects that I have
in the hopper right now that I really I
I I would like to
have uh I would like to have out uh
sometime this year so yeah great
question hun great
question and Jillian says okay that
works for me the basics of antipin
flowers cool we'll do that and then
we'll wrap things up for the night
here all right
so anti-spin
flowers so the first thing to understand
about anti-spin flowers is we're going
to need to make use of something called
a linear isolation a linear isolation is
just moving your hand back and forth in
a straight line and having the POI kind
of poke out to either side as that
happens the way I usually teach people
to do this is start with the POI
spinning clockwise over on your left-
hand side and you want to imagine that
you're going to stall the poy down on
your Center Line so your hand gets
yanked from your left side to your
Center and then you're going to pull
your hand out to your far right side and
that's going to get the pois spinning
clockwise
again from here you want to stall the PO
straight up your Center Line which once
again is going to involve your hand
coming in uh to the center and you want
to kind of sneak your hand underneath
the PO head back over to the left uh
where once again you wind up spinning
clockwise so I stall In The Middle come
out to the right I stall up on the
center line and go out to the left stall
down on my Center Center Line stall up
on my Center Line as I go back and forth
and it's really important I want to make
sure that the direction of the pois
stays consistent it's always clockwise
relative to me so once this gets to feel
pretty comfortable and you can just take
your hand straight back and forth or
sorry I skipped a step there once this
gets to feel comfortable enough
that you can get through the Stalls
pretty easily without any flubs or
anything like that the next step is you
want to to uh reduce the number of Beats
you're doing on each side uh of this
pattern so as the PO is coming around
I'm going to stall down and as the Poise
coming around back up I'm going to stall
up stall down stall up stall down stall
up there's two ways you can think of
this one is that um as the PO going
around you want it to stick out in each
Direction at least once so it sticks out
left down right up left down right up or
you can count the number of beats in it
it's a three beat move this one
sometimes messes with people so don't
take it as the gospel but think you
could doing Left Right excuse me left
center right and back left center
right sorry left center right left
center right left center right left
center right for points where the PO
goes underneath your
hand so once you got that down you're
going to have your hand move with the
poy as it goes through that Center area
so when you stall the poy down your hand
moves down with it and when you stall
the poy up your hand moves up with it so
hand and poy go down hand and poy go up
and the result is a four-petal antipin
flower that's it right there if you can
do both of these stalls and have your
hand move with the PO up and down and
perform it as a three beat move again
thinking left center right left center
right and guess what you've nailed a
four pedal anti- spin flower there is no
downbeat associated with the top petal
there so yeah that's a four pedal
antipin flower huzzah
huzzah and oh Ian whan has jumped in
here hi my friend do you know of any
ribbon po that incorporate LED I do not
I'm afraid I dance more than doing
tricks I'm looking for the grace and
slow slowness regard Ian um no I'm not
familiar with any LED ribbon po I'm
afraid um I will keep an eye out though
or an ear out maybe is is the more is is
more likely
um I swear I've seen a video of it but I
cannot recall who the manufacturer was
um but yeah I don't I don't know of any
manufactur cures of LED ribbon poy off
the top of my head I I am so sorry I
can't help you I
apologize anyway friends so I said I was
going to hang on until quarter past the
hour and we are here if anybody wants to
drop a last minute Super Chat I'd
appreciate it
um yeah thank you all for uh joining me
here tonight I'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up here thank you all for
your wonderful
questions um I hope you learn something
here and um I will be back for another
one of these live stream q&as in
February so keep your eyes peeled almost
certainly oh bloody hell Valentine's Day
is on a Friday isn't it
ah we'll see how that works out I'm not
making any promises right
now um yeah so uh one of the Fridays in
February I will do another one of these
live stream q&as so please keep your
your eyes out yeah awesome thank you all
so much please take care uh stay warm
out there and um yeah I will uh I will
see you all real soon and uh definitely
next month for another one of these um
take care friends take care of each
other take care of yourselves and uh
yeah have a good evening and a weekend
Jillian says I always look forward to
your live streams have a nice night
thank you oh and have a good uh Martin
Luther King Jr day day on
Monday yeah
yeah cool cool alen heisen TV is giving
me one of these good glad to hear it all
right friends um yeah I'm going to hop
off now take care and uh I will see you
all soon peace
hm that's weird
oh there we go